si el presidente de la república
guillermo lasso ha reconocido que
gobernará sin tomar en cuenta a la
asamblea en nacional pero por qué sucede
esta declaración del ejecutivo nacional
específicamente ha sucedido por la
atención que se venía creciendo en
cuanto al programa de gobierno entre el
ejecutivo nacional y la asamblea
nacional específicamente guillermo lasso
emitió recientemente unas declaraciones
donde aseguraba que la asamblea nacional
se ha puesto de espaldas al gobierno
todo esto luego de que la asamblea
nacional
negara el principal plan de gobierno
proyecto ley denominado el proyecto de
ley de inversiones la asamblea nacional
decidió negar este proyecto de ley y
reaccionó el ejecutivo nacional en esto
también sucede paralelamente cuando el
parlamento ha mantenido una especie de
diferencias junto al ejecutivo en
nacional específicamente el primer
mandatario ha asegurado que la asamblea
nacional bloquea sus gestiones de
gobierno y esta podría ser
específicamente lo que el ejecutivo
nacional argumentó para citar así a la
muerte cruzada es un mecanismo
constitucional que le permite al
ejecutivo nacional disolver el
parlamento pero qué pasaría si convoca a
la muerte de cruzada con el ejecutivo
nacional convoca debe esperar el
dictamen de la corte constitucional y
posteriormente que convocaría a
elecciones generales tanto el presidente
de la república como el parlamento se
disolverían y el ejecutivo nacional
tendría que gobernar
durante los próximos seis meses
únicamente bajo decretos leyes para
terminar el periodo de gobierno actual y
luego convocar algunas elecciones y
cambiar así todo el tren ejecutivo pero
finalmente ya el ejecutivo nacional ha
emitido lo que sería como su primer
decreto ha anunciado que ha dividido el
ministerio de gobierno y ya recuperado
nuevamente crear el ministerio de
gobierno y así asigna a un ministro de
gobierno y a un nuevo ministro del
interior